game reviews have returned guys I
apologize I haven't been doing them as
much lately to be honest there hasn't
been that many games that I had a chance
to play
I did play bioshock infinite but i just
i played it so late that i was like yeah
I'm not gonna review it everyone knows
it's a good game but I just recently
played Metro last light over the past
few days and I want to tell you guys my
thoughts on it Metro last light is a
follow-up to Metro 2033 and that game
received pretty good reviews and people
enjoyed the game but it wasn't like a
smash it looks a little bit under the
radar but people still enjoyed the game
and wanted to see more of it in this
game you get a Russian perspective of a
post-apocalyptic world most people are
now underground they use the Metro
tunnels to be able to travel and go
around certain factions if people
believe it or not are still in existence
after the apocalypse there are still
Nazis there are still communists and
above all of them is an atmosphere that
humans cannot breathe now they have to
wear gas masks as well as a whole bunch
of disgusting mutations that can cause
some serious problems if you'd like to
interact with nice little mutations you
find along the way on your morning
stroll so this game is essentially a
first-person shooter but it's also got
some survival horror roots in there as
well which is something that I enjoy if
it's not exploited if it's taken the way
that you would have it in real life like
yeah I want to have more ammo than I
necessarily would need I want to be able
to not have to run around and but people
with my gun and hopefully you know have
maybe a bat or something like I
understand that's how it would be in
real life but in this game they spread
out the ammo conservation fairly well
you'll find it in lockers you'll find it
in little briefcases and whenever you
kill an opponent or an enemy you can
then pick up ammo from the dead body
overall it's a pretty enjoyable game
there are a few issues I had with it but
I'll get into those later the game is a
lot of stealth as well you can choose to
get through various areas by removing
the light which is pretty cool you can
go to an object press square and you can
actually like remove the light bulb all
that is very fun and entertaining but
it's not terribly groundbreaking I think
where this game really shines is its use
of atmosphere it's got a very creepy
vibe to it I really feel like as I
played this game yeah you're underground
in an old abandoned metro tunnel and
there are creatures around here and
there's unbreathable air up there you
don't want to go up there like I really
felt that they really nailed the design
and this world
it was kind of like dead space 3 where
that entire world was so well realized
it was better in dead space 3 but I
think here they did a pretty good job of
recreating what an apocalypse might be
you know there's still warring factions
they added a little bit of a political
thing to the game that I wasn't
expecting one of the biggest issues I do
have with this game is the enemy AI if I
am seen or they are alerted to my
presence I can literally just find some
room somewhere crouch down and basically
just wait for them to crowd the door and
kill him it's just they're stupid
there's one part where I was walking
through this corridor I turned to
hallway and there was a guy just
standing there staring at me
I didn't do anything and I shot him so
some of the enemy AI is a little bit
questionable it's not god-awful or
something like aliens colonial Marines
where the things were just hopping
around and Here I am and they didn't do
anything but it could have been a lot
better there are times and some of the
graphics appear a little bit glitchy
some of the shadows that move along jump
really quick and then disappear and then
reappear again that's not terrible the
graphics aren't awful there are a few
times when people are speaking dialogue
and you feel like their mouth isn't
exactly making the shape that it needs
to make to say the words they're saying
that being said some of the voice acting
could have been a little bit better but
I think for the most part this is a game
that is set on making you in this world
and putting you there and making you
feel like yes you're in this dark creepy
scary post-apocalyptic world and they
succeeded very well in that regard I
played so many games growing up you know
and it's really cool to see a game that
isn't just about the action this game
has some messages to say about the way
humans are they really go a lot of
different places politically and
dramatically in this game that I was
surprised by and pleased to see so
overall there are some technical issues
in this game it's not like a
groundbreaking remarkable game but I
still really enjoyed Metro last light
and I'm going to give it a 7 point 5 out
of 10 it's probably best to may wait for
a used copy or rent it through game fly
or wherever you may rent a game nowadays
overall though I did enjoy this game I
would recommend playing it at some point
in your gaming life thanks as always for
watching guys I'll try to do more game
reviews very soon and as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes